finden wir jetzt landet 9 der mysteriöse
neunte planet ein möglicher neuer planet
unseres sonnensystems forschungsteams
weltweit jagen das phantom und jetzt
liefert fachleute ganz neue erkenntnisse
demnach könnte die umlaufbahn von planet
9 ganz anders sein als bislang gedacht
kommen wir ihm jetzt endlich auf die
spur klicks und science im future gibt
es dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen versteckt
sich da draußen in den äußeren bereichen
des sonnensystems ein neunter bislang
unentdeckter planet diese diskussion
wird schon seit jahren von fachleuten
weltweit geführt und fest steht der
mysteriöse planet 9 bringt
forschungsteams weltweit zum haareraufen
ganz vorne mit dabei
bei dieser suche sind die beiden us
astronom mike brown und konstantin
bettingen vom california institute of
technology
der steckbrief das mysteriöse neun
planeten lautet wie folgt demnach könnte
es sich um einen gesteinsplaneten mit
dem vierfachen ehrt durchmesser handeln
der über die 5 fache masse der erde
verfügt ein gigantischer brocken also um
es mal auf den punkt zu bringen
berechnungen legen nahe dass er zehn bis
20 tausend jahre brauchen könnte um die
sonne in einer langgezogenen umlaufbahn
zum runden versteckt halten könnte er
sich im sogenannten kuiper gürtel diesen
kann man sich wie eine ringförmige zone
am außenrand unseres sonnensystems
vorstellen doch diese sogenannten
transnet typischen objekte sind super
schwierig aufzuspüren denn sie befinden
sich ja jenseits von neptun sind von der
erde aus gesehen extrem nicht schwach
die sonnenstrahlen erreichen sie dort
kaum noch wo genau müssen wir nach ihm
also suchen und wie um himmels willen
könnte canet 9
dort an den rand des sonnensystems
gelangt seien aktuelle berechnungen
haben nun ergeben dass seine umlaufbahn
ganz anders sein könnte als wir bisher
gedacht haben und das wiederum hat große
auswirkungen auf die nervenaufreibende
suche nach dem fest steht trotz
intensiver suche konnte der mysteriöse
planet 9
dessen existenz umstritten ist bislang
nicht aufgespürt werden erinnert ein
wenig an den planeten neptun
auch er wurde viele jahre vor seiner
eigentlichen entdeckung theoretisch
bereits vorher gesagt und zwar aufgrund
von unregelmäßigkeiten in der bahn des
uranus ähnlich verhält es sich jetzt mit
planet 9 trotz intensiver suche bleibt
der riesen planet ein phantom dabei
mangelt es nicht an verschiedenen
anhaltspunkten und indizien für seine
existenz spricht beispielsweise die
ansammlung von kleinen himmelskörpern
jenseits des neptun denn deren bahnen
sind im vergleich zum rest des
sonnensystems äußerst ungewöhnlich und
genau das könnte nach ansicht von
fachleuten an der anziehungskraft eines
bisher unbekannten planeten liegen dazu
der wissenschaftler robert der rosa
obwohl planet neun bisher nicht entdeckt
wurde lässt sich die umlaufbahn des
planeten aus seiner wirkung auf die
verschiedenen objekte im äußeren
sonnensystem ableiten
die suche gestaltet sich so kompliziert
weil sich der körper gürtel schätzung
zufolge über eine gewaltige länge von 6
milliarden bis 50 milliarden kilometer
ziehen könnte und planet 9 soll sich
dahinter befinden weswegen man planet 9
bis heute trotz intensiver suche noch
nicht direkt beobachten konnte liegt
wohl an seiner enormen distanzen
amerikanische wissenschaftler vom
institute of technology california
hatten einmal berechnet dass die bahn
von planet 9 den planeten zu dem
zeitpunkt seiner dichtesten erdniveau
noch immer 700 mal weiter an der sonne
vorbei führt als die erde anfang diesen
jahres 2021 gab es dann einen herben
dämpfer für die planet neunjähriger ein
us forschungsteam hatte die datenlage
und untersuchung zu den bahnen von 14
extremen tns genauer ins visier genommen
die eno steht für transnet tun ihre
objekte meint damit also alle die weit
jenseits des neptuns kreisen die analyse
offenbarte dass die bahnen dieser
objekte auch ohne die anwesenheit eines
namen planeten erklärt werden können in
dieser studie wurde allerdings nur ein
kleiner teil des äußeren sonnensystems
beobachtet sodass selektions
verzerrungen nicht auszuschließen sind
das forschungsteam kamen jedenfalls zu
dem schluss dass die extremen tieren aus
gleichmäßig über die himmel verteilt
sind demnach könnte es also sein dass
die beobachteten ob
nur aufgrund von selektions verzerrung
gehäuft auftauchen dazu schreiben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
das bedeutet nicht dass brandneu nicht
da ist doch seine anwesenheit ist nicht
notwendig um die daten zu erklären die
beiden us-wissenschaftler constantin
bettingen und michael brown dagegen sind
von der existenz von planeten überzeugt
die beiden forscher
man ist übrigens auch die im jahr 2016
das erste mal die existenz eines
potenziellen neunten planeten postuliert
hatten also vorher gesagt haben sie
äußerten sich so zu der studie ihrer
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe alle ihre daten auf unser altes
papier überschrieben wenn man genau
hinschaut sieht man deutlich eine
anhäufung tatsächlich gibt es starke
beweise für planet 9 in ihren daten in
ihrem planet mein blog schreiben sie nun
das neue berechnung nahelegen dass eine
sache allerdings anders aussehen könnte
als bislang gedacht die rede ist von der
umlaufbahn von planet 9 in ihrem fokus
standen die objekte die eine bahn
abweichung zeigen und somit auf die
existenz eines weiteren planeten
schließen lassen
statt der ursprünglichen sechs
abweichler kommen die beiden
astrophysiker nun auf insgesamt 19
objekte die auf planet 9 rückschließen
lassen für ihre modelle nahmen sie
andere ausgangs faktoren als basis als
es in allen anderen bisherigen modellen
der fall war heißt also brown und brett
gehen gehen davon aus dass in den
berechnungen aus der vergangenheit
wichtige faktoren nicht berücksichtigt
worden waren
konkret geht es um die frage ob jedes
objekt das mehr als 10.000 astronomische
einheiten von der sonne entfernt ist für
die inneren regionen des sonnensystems
verloren ist astronomische einheiten
meint in der fachsprache übrigens den
abstand von der sonne zur erde
dazu schreibt das autorenteam was wir
aber nicht bedacht hatten ist der
umstand dass die sonne ja nicht isoliert
von anderen sternen entstanden ist
sondern vermutlich in einer dicht
besetzten sternentstehungsrate gemeinsam
mit vielen anderen jungen sternen
entstand wenn man davon ausgeht könnte
im jungen sonnensystem ein teil der so
genannten orten wolke entstanden sein
dieses reservoir aus den millionen von
kometen beginnt ab einer entfernung von
etwa 1500 astronomischen einheiten
bislang ging man davon aus dass es sich
bei der aschewolke um ein
der passive region handelt doch neue
analysen legen nahe dass es doch objekte
innerhalb dieser region geben könnte
die doch in gewisser art und weise eine
wirkung ausüben was passiert aber wenn
man bei diesen modellen davon ausgeht
dass planet 9 existiert genau diese
fragestellung nahm die beiden us
astrophysiker jetzt genauer unter die
lupe
so kommt man zu ganz neuen erkenntnissen
zitat aufgrund der langzeit schwerkraft
wirkung vom planeten über jahrmillionen
hinweg können einige objekte aus der
inneren mission wolke wieder in die
region des äußeren sonnensystems so wird
gelangen
wenn das passiert ist so muss man sich
fragen was mit diesen objekten passiert
ist in ihren simulationen nahmen die
beiden wissenschaftler mögliche
wechselwirkungen vom planet neuen
galaktischen gezeiten kräften und
vorbeiziehenden sternen genauer ins
visier so kamen sie dann zu dem
folgenden ergebnis solche eingefangenen
objekte könnten sich im laufe der zeit
mit objekten aus dem kult budget
vermischt haben so könnten sie ebenfalls
teilweise zu der ansammlung gehören die
im kupfergürtel lokalisiert ist und
durch abweichende bank adressiert sind
im klartext würde das dann wiederum
bedeuten dass einige der sogenannten t
hinaus im kupfergürtel ihren ursprung
ganz woanders haben
diese könnten also aus der inneren
region der ochsenbrücke stammen die
ansammlung dort wäre also kleiner als
die im kupfergürtel der sich ja näher an
der sonne befindet als die aschewolke
demnach müsste die umlaufbahn von planet
noch elliptischer sein als man bislang
dachte so der umkehrschluss des us
autoren teams unbeantwortet bleibt aber
die frage welcher der abweichenden
objekte seinen ursprung in der option
wolke hat da das weiter rätselhaft
bleibt sei es unmöglich die umlaufbahn
vom planet 9 ganz genau zu bestimmen
dennoch zeigen sie sich optimistisch
dass wir den suchradius weiter
einschränken können und sich somit die
schlinge um planet 9 weiter zuzieht
beginn und brown gehen weiter davon aus
dass der mysteriöse planet in den
kommenden zehn jahren aufgespürt werden
kann hoffnung setzen sie beispielsweise
in das werra sie jubeln aufs rad um das
in zwei jahren 2023 in betrieb gehen
soll
es handelt sich um ein spiegelteleskop
das den zugänglichen
in drei nächten komplett fotografieren
kann ist planet 9 ein schwarzes loch ja
das ist auch eine these mehr dazu gibt
es in diesem video also anklicken
anschauen und diesen kanal klicks um
science and future abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran